you know by now that's serving one
single file for every context is not a
good idea yeah I mean the image file you
would want to serve for a large display
size on a big high definition TV it's
totally inappropriate for a watch for
example so how do you serve the right
image for every combination of device
capability and display size in the last
lesson you learned some techniques that
use CSS background images in media
queries to display different images for
different viewport sizes that kind of
works but it was pretty messy and
difficult to debug to do it properly you
potentially needed to write CSS to
handle umpteen different use cases and
what about the future what if all your
fancy media queries don't support some
future platform yeah I mean using media
queries like this is an attempt to guess
at Build time
what image file will be best at runtime
you're forcing image choice on the
browser rather than giving the browser
information to make the best choice
possible the other problem with media
queries is that they only refer to the
viewport dimensions not the actual
display size of the image what if you
give your image a percentage with say
around 50% of the viewport width media
queries won't help